[Music]
hello everyone welcome back for a brand
new tip 2019 interview we have the
director of the lighthouse here Robert
Eggers Wow
congratulations I saw it last night I
feel like my brain is scrambled in the
best way and I barely know where to
start with this so a couple years ago we
spoke right when the witch was coming
out and at that point in time you had
told me that you were hopefully planning
to do the nos for a new movie next so
I'm curious what was the transition from
where your mind that was with your next
project then to making the lighthouse
your firm second feature I developed a
couple larger things and and as one
finds when one is negotiating their way
in in this crazy business it doesn't
always happen the way you think it might
have been in fact it was fraught to was
something that I wanted to do later but
then I had the opportunity to do it
sooner but then it seemed like actually
it wasn't going that way so it's just
kind of the lighthouse became the thing
that people wanted to greenlight so that
became the movie that I wanted to make
because I could what is the elevator
pitch for the lighthouse the I I didn't
have a good elevator pitch luckily Artie
features who worked with me on the witch
and a24 who worked with me on the witch
because we had that relationship they
were happy to read the read the script
without a pitch exactly and and and a
New Regency decided to jump in and take
the plunge as well so they were all very
brave and what's it like giving them a
script like this do you have to also
give like visual references other things
because I imagine that what I just
experienced last night probably can't be
fully felt through the page I I make a
lot of look books so there was like a
general lookbook that gave the vibe and
atmosphere of the whole film and then
an extensive lookbook about the costumes
an extensive lookbook about all the
structures that were built and the
storms and everything like that so did
you build everything where every every
every building you see in the movie we
we made completely and is there anything
about it that's specifically designed to
suit your crew because I'm also
wondering about what the the black and
white style does I don't know with
things like lighting that many people
out there might not expect the well so
with the witch we we shot nearly
everything with with natural light or
flame double X black-and-white film
stock hasn't changed since the 1950s and
takes an incredible amount of light so
all of the kerosene lanterns whether
they're on a table or a sconce had like
extremely light bright light bulbs in
them with that worth set to flicker so
so so we had to have wires and things
hidden and installed to light with black
and white and and additionally in the in
interior lighthouse tower the it was
only eight feet in diameter so we needed
to be able to move walls around in order
to get the camera in there oh boy this
sounds nice and complicated yeah it also
sounds really badass when you say like
we made our film with natural light in
flame like that should just be a thing
that should just be there when you were
casting this was it always Willem Dafoe
and Robert Pattinson because these
performances are seared in my brain I
can't imagine it any other way
yeah absolutely I mean luckily you know
Rob and I had been looking for something
in Willem and I had been looking for
something so when this seemed like it
could be the next thing boom you know
but were the first burning questions
they had for you after reading the
script uh well they each wanted to know
who is playing the other person you know
that was the most burning question and
they were both excited by the idea of
working with
the other and when I walked out of the
movie like I had had this experience
that kind of really transported me into
another world but it's a very
challenging movie you don't give any
easy answers so for them when you're
working with them do you have to explain
everything to a tee all of your
intentions or do you let them roll with
however they interpret it sometimes
there's specific things they need to
explain sometimes not rob would often
ask me about his characters past and be
like is it this is it this is it this is
that is this is this and I would say any
of those work for me as long as you say
the line 10% faster and I don't mean
that to be to be flip it's that it's
that like any of those choices work with
with what's going on with the character
because the audience never learns the
like those specific things so Rob can
carry whatever he wants in it as long as
I can capture this certain ambiguity
that I'm looking for on screen that it
feels truthful you know I'm saying
absolutely what is it like when you're
in the Edit room with something like
this again ambiguity challenging piece
what's that point where you realize like
this this cut is interesting it's going
to spark discussion but it's also to be
a satisfying film for all my viewers I
think we were just trying to get it as
short as we could the I don't parts
partially because Jaron and I are so
slow but it's also because the DP but
it's also because we we are really
specific about what we're shooting and
we don't shoot coverage and we don't
there's not a lot left on the
cutting-room floor it's very specific
this is what we have and so so there's
not tons of choices it's more like what
you take do we use okay sometimes
because we make these specific choices
and we do these long shots Louise for
the editor and I gets painted into a
corner and
you know I I'm I'm very pleased with the
film I think it could be ten minutes
shorter but not we didn't not was what
we shot with what we shot we we got it
to where it needs to be you know I'm
saying oh wow we would have had to take
taking script pages out I don't want to
get into spoilers right now but it is
there anything that in the Edit when you
were locking your final cut that you
were wavering on whether or not to
include no no that's the thing like
everything that's in there needs to be
in there okay because I can't think of a
single moment to take out no no I mean I
agree with you I want to know now a
little bit about working with Willem and
Rob on set specifically when it comes to
like the super emotional scenes I mean
actually not even just like the
emotional beats even moments where like
Rob is wheeling something around that
looks like legit heavy pushing something
up a staircase how many times can you
shoot certain scenes with them are there
any particular ones where you're like we
got to do this in one take for their
sake or it's not gonna be okay the only
things that were one take what was giant
waves destroying things those are the
only one take things the and and burying
well as a spoiler but like burying
Willem we didn't we couldn't do many
takes out beyond miserable the other
thing I mean you see a little bit of
water in the grave which is like a
little bit of texture but actually
there's a lot of water in the grave and
so it was also like bone-chilling ly
cold on top of everything else
oh my there's just like one thing after
the next in this movie that sounds like
the biggest production challenge in the
world to me so what was the most
challenging scene to shoot period
honestly there are so many challenging
scenes I think we were using three
different periods of camera equipment
like cobbled together to make this thing
in the pouring rain with gale force
winds with dolly and crane all
and so the gear it was constantly
breaking down and and didn't want to be
fixed easily because these were things
that didn't like come together very
easily so so every so often when we were
out and and the weather was what it
needed to be to tell the story we were
moving incredibly slowly because the
camera kept breaking down what camera
did you use because it's a really old
camera right well the camera body is not
a particularly old Panavision camera
body but we were using lenses from as
early as 1918 and his late is like 1938
there were rehoused I'm just picturing
like super old lenses like that with
waves crashing down on their it was
crazy
a couple of teeny tiny details that I
wanted to ask you back they really
caught my eye the tattoo on Willems
chest does that have a meaning how did
you come up with putting that there just
looking at pictures of old sailors that
was a nice sailor tattoo that he found
he actually has a bunch of small ones on
his arms that they never really read but
he has a bunch of little tattoos on his
arms I'm slightly obsessed with tattoos
so I feel like my eye is automatically
drawn to that type of thing I just want
to backtrack really quickly because I'm
curious what is like the teeny tiny
nugget of an idea that inspired this
whole thing my brother who I wrote this
with had an idea for a very different
movie that was a ghost story in a
lighthouse and I was like that's a
really good idea but then a couple
months later I said how's that
lighthouse movie coming he's like not so
great and I as if I could take a crack
at it
so then I immediately thought it needed
to be a period movie and and and
eventually we ended up collaborating on
it together I also want to know a little
bit about their Styles Willemijn Roberts
styles do they have the same approach to
their craft and what happens when you're
working with two actors that like to
work with you as an actor's director
differently
well everybody needs something different
as a performer and as a person and so
it's it's my job to find what Willem
needs and what Rob needs within the
umbrella of this is you know how I work
as a director um but but but certainly
they work very differently and Willem
loves to rehearse and and would you know
asked me to his little fisherman's
cottage to like work on monologues and
beat them out as if we were doing a
theater piece Rob there was some
necessary rehearsing to learn the
blocking and just that was something
that Rob did not want because he wanted
to surprise Willem and myself with with
what he was gonna do to surprise himself
with what he was gonna do well so so he
felt like he you know he wasn't really
into into rehearsals and and and Rob
tends to be like very very great on a
first or second take and then and then
take some time before he has another
like really home run
take Willem is like does different
textures of different things at all
times so so it's so it is when you're
doing a like a scene that is like one
long shot yeah that's tricky it's sort
out so you work with these two greats in
the industry I assume you have all the
hopes in the world that they're gonna be
phenomenal and they are but is there any
specific moment in the movie where they
just went so far above what you were
expecting from them that it blew even
your mine I mean most of the time
Willem when he's tearing down Rob and
screams liar like so
with so much fierce force and of course
his long like cursing monologue the
Shakespearean meltonian monologue and I
know that Rob does much more interesting
nuanced things but his screaming at
the end is superhuman yeah
superhuman the way he's like like like
like how like like I don't think people
understand how how much commitment it
takes to do that it really did kind of
cross my mind while I was watching the
movie and I heard that that like I did
not know that individual was capable of
producing that so it really startled me
yeah I am gonna cut this portion of our
interview off here and say thank you for
joining us for this conversation thank
you to our wonderful sponsors Nordstrom
Canada if you want more on the
lighthouse you just gotta wait and it's
worth the wait you're gonna want to see
it when it hits theaters and then you're
gonna want to come back to Collider
video because we're gonna talk a few
spoilers but right now we're gonna say
goodbye like and share this video and
we'll be back soon with more Tiff's
coverage